Speaker 1: Let's go next to Julius
from Idaho. Julius, you're on the air.
All right, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: All right. So I was just wondering,
do you think the Ukraine war isn't?
Speaker 1: OK, so you cut out what we
heard you say was, do I think the Ukraine
Speaker 2: get away with taking care
of its citizens? What we heard
Speaker 1: when you cut out was,
do I think the Ukraine war and then you
cut out? So what? What was the rest of the
question? Do I think the Ukraine war? What?
Speaker 2: Do you think the Ukraine war is
an excuse for the US to get away
with taking care of its citizens
just, you know, regular Bernie Sanders policies?
Speaker 1: And no, I'm not sure I even
understand the question is the Ukraine war.
Oh, an excuse for who to get away with it.
Speaker 2: The US, like their politicians,
like I'm saying, like so for example, if Biden
were to legalize marijuana, which he isn't OK,
do you think he can still just get away
with not legalizing marijuana because
they're like focusing on the Ukraine war?
Speaker 1: No, I think he was going to be
able to get away with it regardless. I don't think
he had any. And remember, the real discussion was
decriminalization as far as Biden's concerned. I
don't think he was ever really interested in it,
and I think he'll be able to get away with
not doing it regardless of what's happening
in Ukraine. OK. All right, thank you. All right,
thank you for the call. There's Julius from Idaho